guys I'm Ryan right guys I'm Dan Seibert
uncharted 4 gameplay demo released at e3
2015 Dan shut your [ __ ] mouth
he does here's my lady calls me
I'm a man of fortune of a seek my
fortune
change of scenery oh man that's good
there's such an adventurous life to a
char that's so unique mmm great gets
here let's not stick around to find out
human fate
always dick three guy
all right in the day all about the dick
[ __ ]
this game looks amazing looks so good it
looks amazing like genuinely
guys at Naughty Dog I'm a [ __ ] beer
it's attention to details in the little
touch
this feels like a little [ __ ]
action/adventure Oh Oh jump on that
[ __ ] oh my god
he's really gonna dodge yeah real class
useful AI that's new and sound effects
on the budget
No No Oh
the HRT Heatblast action love painting
I'm playing for all three tonight that
detail food cart you run over strangers
really not doors
destroy
I really hope I learned all these
shortcuts okay I can navigate like
it's like a it's like an actual active
adventurous play this is driving through
the mall level what is this engine is
running on it's incredible
why they acknowledge that
see that Chuck get past that
Wow they home this is so cool this is so
good this is really [ __ ] cool man
right okay yeah
and Aparna
I feel like [ __ ] watch this
and
just just this on
do you like in a world like you I'm so
like in it yeah feels like it's never
ending
oh whoa yes [ __ ] yes
ouch
oh here's gnats so if your snaps look
yeah that is a hot yoga holy [ __ ] out
looks awesome
that looks [ __ ] awesome dude this
I've seen many III trailers but that one
I was like I know question to ask I am
getting this game like this is why I
bought a PlayStation 4 over Xbox one is
because of that [ __ ] yeah
tension 2d that everything was
destructible you haven't say I'm gonna
get an Xbox one but I'm for sure getting
a place you don't you're done I'm
getting PlayStation 4 you got Metal Gear
Lee Uncharted yeah I'm doing this man a
[ __ ] stove I mean this this is an e3
trailer like this I mean if you look at
some of the trailers that we've watched
thus far so if you've seen the halo 5
reaction from us we're like oh yeah that
looks like a pretty good game you know
looks like good combat that's
Microsoft's flagship franchise so right
right
that's their big one this is one of
Playstations many flagship things and
this blows halo 5 out of the [ __ ]
water
it blows a lot of games out of the water
yeah open-world games are always awesome
to me but I really felt like I'm in the
world right yeah it wasn't just like and
now we're in generic like flatline yeah
nobody exactly get to a point where
you're kind of stuck here it feels like
you know you're just this is this goes
for this is really big yeah this is the
[ __ ] City get away from the time
replicated the entire so yeah that was
awesome it I just love the adventurous
vibe that I'm Charter provides is so
unique like it just feels like an actual
adventure you know like it's that fun
adventure just driving around like you
ran into those poles like in any other
game up until now like you run into
those smaller poles and suddenly your
car just comes to a screeching halt yeah
he ran through it because of actual
physics yeah what would actually happen
if you ran into a pole
well yeah I was well worth it guys god
damn anyway guys thanks for saying that
was out if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real
Jex you can check out dansgaming channel
that cyber channel fun [ __ ] on their
head you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter and vine I'm in a good
mood let's watch let's do a shout out
hmm Julien Nevaeh's I don't know if this
is the right place for a shout-out
because I'm kind of new but I've been
enjoying your videos a lot now you
really put a guy and I'm actually from
Alyssa be crazy channel I know her yeah
yeah dan is gabbing with her and I likes
girls videos you all do together I would
really like a shout-out please I was
going to do an interesting awkward
knock-knock joke but I feel like this is
already too long you probably have other
people give a shout out to you oh yeah
you're pretty tough watching all those
fatalities and brutalities that's way
too much nasty violence so it must be
our serial killers are created Thank You
Julian for saying that 10 people may
call me a [ __ ] over that then I have to
do another video to prove them out [ __ ]
about for to prove my [ __ ] but Julian
and niveles hey speaking of [ __ ] Julian
the bells he probably gets a lot of
posted sexy name man finder Julian I'm
like this guy's gonna be one sexy
[ __ ] his pants drop yeah dude
that's the key to being sexy is you just
got change your name you know you think
my real name is Ryan right it's all
Fredo Garcia and you're black so yeah
Julian with a big black [ __ ] you get a
lot of PU SS ie thanks thanks for for
coming and joining us today hot coming
[ __ ]